I thought I would mention one other
problem that arises that you can ask
about polygons you could ask is there
what's called a periodic orbit when I
say orbit that might be started off at a
point you bounce off the walls and after
some long number of times can you always
find a path that repeats itself so let
me give one very very classical example
of that and that goes back to the square
if you start let's say on the bottom and
move off at a right angle 90 degrees you
move to the top now when you get to the
top because these are parallel this
angle is also 90 degrees and so the
billiard path says you rebound where
angle of reflection equals angle of
incidence and that means that when you
come to the side you will bounce off
exactly the way that you came in you
will you will come to the side and
bounce right back you'll come back along
this line and then you will bounce and
repeat yourself so that's what's called
periodic there are other periodic lines
so for example you could start at a 45
degree angle
everything would be 45 degrees and you
would come back right where you started
and then repeat yourself in fact if you
start at any point at any angle that is
a rational number of a quotient of two
integers if you started with an angle of
27 degrees starting here you will come
back after a certain number of bounces
that's true for a square and in fact one
can prove for any rational polygon where
all the angles are fractions of 180
degrees or P over Q times 180 degrees
again I like to write it like that you
can always find a periodic orbit no not
from any point there's some periodic
orbit from somewhere some periodic orbit
from somewhere there might be so there
will be some direct some point in some
direction where there will be a periodic
orbit example on this saw if there are
none but there is one sitting over here
well yeah usually what happens if it in
most cases that's that's possible in
fact you can always find periodical
that will hit every side in most cases a
periodic orbit will hit aside there
might be other points on that side where
the orbit in that same direction is not
periodic so in other words you start at
a point on a side and move in a
direction it might close up meaning
periodic but if you move the point a
little bit and set it off in the same
direction what could happen is that it
isn't periodic look what might happen is
it hits a corner and then you don't know
what to do that's different from the
square in the square no matter where I
started if I went in 45 degrees it would
be periodic but in a general rational
polygon that may not be the case I want
to talk about triangles now that are not
necessarily rational but just triangles
if they're acute which means all of the
angles are 90 degrees or less what you
could do is you could take the vertex of
the triangle and drop a perpendicular
down to the opposite side to get a point
and then drop this perpendicular down to
the opposite side and get a point so
these are right angles this triangle
joining those points gives a periodic
orbit meaning if I start here I go to a
line towards here this angle will equal
that angle and I'll bounce like that and
then I'll get to this point and this
angle will equal this angle and I'll
bounce like that and I come back this
angle equal this angle and I'll repeat
myself this example was has been known
for hundreds of years I don't think it
was ever thought of as billiards but
anybody in high school or even junior
high could do this in trigonometry when
you do obtuse triangles you can't drop a
perpendicular because if I started at
this vertex and dropped a perpendicular
it wouldn't be on that side that's
because this angle is bigger than 90
degrees and in fact for something as
very simple as a triangle obtuse
triangle one does not know whether there
are periodic orbits so this is a famous
unsolved problem in a subject of what
this is called as dynamical systems well
so again if the obtuse triangle
is rational then there are periodic
orbits so I'm talking about obtuse try
ingles I think I gave an example 90
times square root of 2 that particular
one I would not be able to tell you if
it had a periodic orbit there are some
some recent were people by very very
hard work
if shown if this angle is less than a
hundred degrees then there are periodic
orbits but that was very very hard work
and if it was 110 degrees again I'm
assuming not rational then we don't know
the answer if it's rational we always
know if all the angles if this is a
hundred and eleven and this is 36 what's
left 33 degrees there will be but if one
of the angles is an irrational number
then we don't know so what is greatness
away to someone connected well it's it's
there is a very prominent one of the
most prominent mathematicians in the
United States or in the world in the
subject of dynamical systems whose name
is Professor kkatalk at Penn State has
listed this as one of the five
outstanding problems in dynamical
systems but there's nothing you could do
you can try desperately to solve it but
if it hasn't been solved for hundred
years you probably aren't going to you
know it's only given to one person so to
speak to solve a particular one of these
problems so when you stew it and here's
an atmosphere of resignation